all right the house set to vote any
minute on making the impeachment inquiry
into President Biden official as his son
claims magga Republicans are targeting
him and his family Hunter Biden showing
up on Capitol Hill this morning and
defiantly ducking the closed door
deposition Republicans had set up for
him instead of honoring a congressional
subpoena the president's son demanding a
public hearing while lashing out at the
GOP lawmakers who wanted to question him
for 6 years I have been the target of
the unrelenting Trump attack machine
shouting where's
Hunter well here's my
answer I am here but I'm also here today
to correct how the Maga wri has
portrayed me for their political
purposes Republicans do not
want an open process where Americans can
see their
tactics expose their baseless inquiry or
hear what I have to
say what are they afraid
of I'm here I'm ready but hunter Biden
choosing his words very carefully on if
his father Joe Biden was involved in his
business dealings listen here my father
was not financially involved in my
business not as a practicing lawyer not
as a board member of barisma not my
partnership with a Chinese private
businessman not in my investments at
home nor abroad and certainly not as an
artist you catch that so the first son
speaking out on camera coming as a shock
to most people but apparently not for
President
Biden the president was certainly
familiar uh with what his son was going
to say and I think what you saw was from
the heart from uh his son when it comes
to the president and the first lady they
are proud of him uh continuing to
rebuild his life they are proud of their
son so what comes next for Hunter the
top Republicans James comr and Jim
Jordan not letting his subpoena snub
slide they are pledging to initiate 10
proceedings against against the first
son Jesse Waters I'm sure you were
watching this but you know a lot about
it when he said my father was not
financially involved did your ears perk
up well that's a lie and even if he
wasn't financially involved he's
logistically involved he's personally
involved he's politically involved
because when you fly your son to 15
countries you're logistically involved
when you're personally involved
politically involved when you're meeting
with all of his clients at the White
House of the vice president's residents
at the golf course at the Four Seasons
in Los Angeles you're pretty involved
and then when you're doing favors for
the clients uh like when you're firing
the prosecutor writing the ukrainians a
blank check or you're not popping the
balloon or you're shutting down the FBI
task force of China or you're lifting
Trump tariffs on cheap solar panels yeah
you're doing favors you're writing
letters of recommendation for the people
come on everybody knows he's involved
now Hunter says he's ready he's not not
ready he was not going to testify today
and he says he's here he wasn't in
Congress he was on the Senate he's going
to have to get arrested for contempt
because Bannon tried to do the same
stunt Navaro tried the same stunt didn't
work they were both handcuffed the Trump
family had to sit for depositions they
sat for house senate depositions hours
they didn't pull theatric like that
there's no way he's going to get away
with this and he's racking up another
charge this guy has some nerve I love
how we say that you know this guy is
clean and Joe Biden's clean so where's
the 1.6 million in cash that Hunter
Biden withdrew over three years no one's
curious about where the cash went is it
sewn into windbreakers in Joe's closet
like gold Bob I mean you got missing
cash you got missing diamonds no one's
curious about where all this goes
I mean you got Hunter you got Hunter
Biden um in 2018 according to Dave Weiss
in the
indictment the indictment says Hunter
Biden made $2.1 million in 2018 and he
goes there was no evidence of any
business he didn't conduct any business
and there was no business travel so
Hunter Biden is being indicted for not
paying taxes on his
bribes that's what's going on here and
why were people bribing Hunter Biden
because he was selling access to the
Biden brand obviously what's his legal
positioning judge or your your thoughts
on it well first of all in a not so
legal phraseology Hunter Biden gave uh
Congress the middle finger today uh
Hunter Biden is bound by the law just
like Steve Bannon and just like
everybody else has been held in contempt
Steve Bannon from the time he refused to
come in and honor The subpoena within a
year he was sentenced so I mean this can
move very quickly and it must there has
to be respect for law you can't go out
there and say you know my father loves
me and I had a problem and the magga
people are after me no the magga people
are not after you Hunter what the magga
people and every other American are
after is equal justice they don't want
to hear about a guy making millions of
dollars in foreign countries and then
watching the policy play out in this C
country where it seems to benefit the
other countries as Jesse has so
eloquently laid out whether it's popping
the balloon whether it's 3 days after um
there is a meeting and his son is told
about the prosecutor on barisma three
days later after Hunter calls his father
Joe gets on a plane to Ukraine and
threatens with a billion dollars of our
money get that prosecutor off my son's
company because that business B was
corrupt it was going down and the bidens
had to make sure that it could pass
muster on Wall Street that's what that
was all about and when when Hunter Biden
says my father was not financially
involved as a prosecutor every antenna
goes up so if your father was not
financially involved first you know your
he Joe says he knows nothing of his
son's business next he's not involved in
his business now he's not financially
involved then it begs the question and
it begs an impeachment inquiry how was
he involved then if he wasn't
financially tell me all the circuitous
ways he was involved and we do that with
the emails we do it with a so-called
stolen laptop which he's already
admitted is his and there is proof
pictures photographs emails business
partners and the crazy part of this
thing is he says I want to speak in
front of the United States people wait a
minute wasn't the wasn't it the
Democrats Jesse who had that impeachment
inquiry in the bottom of the basement of
the house where Nancy Pelosi said for
two years you know we've got to do it
down here we don't want anybody upstairs
interfering they destroyed all the tapes
and then they destroyed the tap and the
last thing I want to say the last point
I want to make is this stop with this
drug addiction nonsense because a lot of
the counts in the latest indictment are
post addiction all you have to do is
read his book and know that he was no
longer addicted and he still wasn't
paying taxes he said several times Greg
that it's the magga Republicans that are
coming after me so it's like you might
be able to get the media to write that
story for a couple of days but Chris
Murphy is a Democrat from Connecticut
Senator friendly with the bidens of
course he over the weekend he said that
a lot of the charges seem legitimate to
him mhm I it was it was a stunning press
conference stunning for me to finally
see Hunter speak with pants on it was
disorienting it's like seeing Santa
without his shirt on or Jesse without
his hairpiece you just can't handle it
and to see his mouth move minus a
crackpipe or a straw it's like watching
Lazarus do a backflip it was bizarre he
snubbed the closed door deposition
because he doesn't like anything closed
including his laptop or his bath robe
and he says he wants a public hearing
because he probably didn't notice the L
in public but I will say this I will say
uh I still would take him over his dad
as president because this guy gets it
done this guy's successful he's an
American success story to get all that
and and um and uh the judge is right it
I mean it's easy for us to focus on the
hilarity and tragedy of his lifestyle
but it's also easy for him to exploit
addiction as a shield there are millions
of people with drug and alcohol
addictions who didn't do these things
Millions who didn't leverage political
power and influence for foreign cash
people with addictions who didn't deny
their own child or try to blame an erron
gun on illegal aliens or repeatedly lie
to authorities or enjoy the protections
of a famous name there are millions of
addicts who didn't do that he just got a
lot of breaks he got more breaks than a
million junkies so I'm glad that he's
making amends far be it from me to judge
but you can't blame others for impugning
your own character especially when it
was a one man show and I mean you know
who else gets a I mean talk about breaks
who else a firsttime artist gets an
exhibit in SoHo selling snot for
hundreds of thousands of dollars and we
have no idea who's paying you know he he
can play the victim card but no one else
was filming him naked it wasn't Maga
Republicans they weren't po the mag
Republicans weren't pointing Firearms
near you know terrified sex workers you
know Maga workers won't slightly
implying that if you don't do what he
says you know the big guy might you know
come around and Maga Republicans didn't
write the emails about the big guy so I
think the only way that Hunter is a
victim is he's a victim of his dad
running for president I think he was
doing all this stuff under the
assumption that Dad was retiring and he
was building a big vast retirement fund
for for Joe and then Joe all of a sudden
is running and he's like holy crap
you're out of your mind and then well he
was is still is but now Hunter is like
holy crap now the spotlights on him all
right Jessica you have the floor great
so much to choose from I'm like a lazy
Susan of crazy we pick a CP okay so I
look forward
to most likely be Jesse who will next
have Jim Jordan on your show and you can
ask him about the subpoena from the
January 6 committee that he's flouted
for years now hasn't turned up no
respect for the rule of the law as uh
judge Puro would say so you can list all
these other people but I want to see Jim
Jordan being pushed on that and I think
you're the man to do it Hunter was subed
by Jan 6 yeah and he skipped it yeah I
so he can get arrested great so we're
arresting the arresting people
okay oh right because we control all of
law control doj oh okay um hter made a
lengthy statement about why he wanted to
testify in public and there's some
important details in it and I understand
that he got subpoena a certain way for a
closed door testim testimony but it
matters when he gives clear examples of
the fact that Republicans have
completely
distorted his record his bank records
his emails and we saw what they did with
the Devon Archer testimony right they
emerged from that saying Deon Archer
said that Joe Biden was behind this Etc
and then you listen to the other people
in the room you listen to like Dan
Goldman for instance and then eventually
the transcript was produced where Deon
Archer said the complete opposite that
Joe Biden wasn't personally profiting
from this there was no evidence of it
Victor shoken was not fired by Joe Biden
to protect his son first of all Joe
Biden could not have gotten the entire
International Community to do it um it's
just a load of whoie that's that's there
was no large International Community
course there was even D Christine lard
it was after the community no yes it is
the heads of it's not one person and
it's Senate Republicans a whole bunch of
them Republicans are freaking out
because the beginnings of this
impeachment inquiry which has been going
on or fact finding has been going on
since they took the majority about a
year ago has turned up absolutely
nothing really yeah really and again I
say you should be leading or you should
be leading judge um because Jim comr is
not up to this Jim Jordan site him again
on with vanney talking about what the
impact is going to be driving down
Biden's poll numbers Troy Nells or Neils
I don't know how to pronounce his name
said the same thing what's going to be
the outcome of the impeachment inquiry
Trump 2024
baby this morning Maria bomo has Nancy
Mason she says hey Nancy nice to see you
this morning thanks for getting up early
with us um what you got right where are
the policy changes that came as a result
of being paid off Nancy Ma I don't have
anything I said go get another I love
being with you but had the committee if
you have all the answers Congressman Don
Bacon probably not about uh Biden
committing High crimes and misdemeanors
Chuck Grassley I have no evidence where
I can say the president is guilty GOP
AIDS obviously they don't want to lose
their jobs an unmitigated disaster comr
has lost control and he has botched this
bad the whole catch your breath I could
just name one right there so the Russian
billionaire gave him $3.5 million and a
Porsche Panorama and then he left the
lady off the sanctions list right there
so we have we'll have more to come on
this and within a month that's a policy
within a month The Russian Lady and
Hunter meet with the head of Biden he
gets put on the board of bis one thing
we can be sure of the commercial break
is going to be real hot all right hi
everyone I'm Brian kilme I want you to
do me a favor I want you to click to
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube page
this is the only way that I know for
sure that you're not going to miss any
great commentary any great news bites
any great interviews coming your way on
Fox you can get it all here on YouTube
so subscribe
right now